OPERATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, we're now, kind
of on the home stretch, and
we're entering the part of the
course, that's actually my
favorite part of the course.
I can't promise it will be
your favorite part of the
course, but I hope so, at
least for many of you.
Throughout the term, we've been
talking about ways to
solve problems using
computation.
And one of the key lessons that
I hope you're beginning
to absorb is that we might use
a completely different way to
solve a problem with the
computer than we would have
used if we didn't have
a computer handy.
In particular, we might often
use brute force, which you've
never use with a pencil and
paper, we might not do the
mental gyrations required to
try and formulate a closed
form solution, but just guess
a bunch of answers using
successive approximation
until we got there.
A number of different
techniques.
And that's really what we're
going to be doing for the rest
of the term now.
Except we won't be talking about
algorithms per se, or
not very much.
Instead we'll be talking about
more general techniques for
using computers to solve
problems that
are actually hard.
They don't just look
hard, they in many
cases really are hard.
The plan of the next set of
lectures is, I want to start
with a simple example to
give you a flavor of
some of these issues.
In the course of going through
that example, I'll illustrate
some both thinking tools and
some software tools that can
be used for tackling
the example.
Then abstract from the example
to try and put in a more
general framework.
And then, dive back down and use
that framework to tackle a
series of other interesting
problems.
Some things I would like you do
think about learning along
the way, is moving from an
informal problem description
to a more formal problem
statement.
So that's, in part, what we
did with the optimization
problems, right?
We looked at an informal
description about optimizing
your way through the MIT
curriculum, and then could
formulate it using sigmas and
other bizarre notation to try
and formalize what we were
really trying to do.
And we did that as a preamble
to writing any code.
First understand the problem,
formally, and then
move on to the code.
And we won't always
be totally formal.
I often like to use the word
rigorous instead of formal.
Implying that it won't look like
math, per se, but it'll
be precise and relatively
unambiguous.
So that will be one thing that
I want you to think about as
we go through these problems.
Another thing is inventing
computational models.
Almost every meaningful program
we write is in some
sense modeling the
actual world.
For writing a program to figure
out how to keep a
bridge from falling down, we're
modeling the physics of
bridges and wind and
things like that.
If we're writing a program to
try and help us decide what
stocks to buy or sell, we're
trying to model the stock
market in some sense.
If we're trying to figure out
who's going to win the Super
Bowl, we're modeling football
teams. But almost every
problem, you build a piece of
software, and you hope that it
has some ability to
mimic the actual
situation you care about.
And it's not the program we care
about, per se, it's the
world, and the program is merely
a mechanism to help us
understand the world better.
And so we're going to ask the
question, have we built a good
model, in the computation,
that gives us
insight into the world?
As we do this, we'll see that
we'll be dealing with and
exploiting randomness.
Depending upon your outlook of
life, one of the sad things in
the world or one of the happy
things in the world, is that
it's unpredictable.
And things happen either at
random or seemingly at random.
It may be that if we had a deep
enough understanding at
the level of single atoms of
the way the world works, we
could model the weather and
discover that, in fact, the
weather patterns are not
random but entirely
predictable.
Since we can't do that, we
have to assume that they
really are random, and we build
models of the weather
that assume a certain amount
of randomness in it.
Maybe if we understood the stock
market well enough, we
could have predicted the
collapse in October.
But since nobody does understand
it well enough,
when people model the stock
market they assume that
there's a certain amount of
randomness, certain amount of
stochastic things.
So, as far as we can observe
the world, almost every
interesting part of the world
has randomness in it.
And so when we build models, we
will have to build models
that are, if we want to be
formal, we'll talk about a
stochastic, which is just a
fancy way of saying they
incorporate randomness.
So we haven't yet done that
this semester, but almost
everything we do from here on
in, we will deal with a
certain amount of randomness.
What else are we going
to be looking at?
We'll be looking at the notion
of making sense of data.
As we look at, again, modeling
the world, what we discover,
there's a lot of
data out there.
If you work at Walmart and
you're trying to decide what
to stock on the shelves, you're
building a model of
what the customers might buy
under certain circumstances,
and that model is going to
take account the entire
history of what customer's have
bought in the past. And
that's, if you're Walmart,
a lot of data.
And so given that you have a
lot of data about what's
happened in the past, how can
we interpret that, for
example, to get insight
into the future?
And we do a lot of that.
And so we will, for example,
look at how can we draw
pictures that help us visualize
what's going on with
the data, rather than trying to
read say, a million numbers
and inferring something
from them.
This is a big part of what
people do with computers, is
try and figure out
how to understand
large amounts of data.
And then finally, as we go
through this last third of the
course, I want to spend
time in evaluating
the quality of answers.
It's easy to write a program
that spits out a number, or
string, or anything else.
What's hard is to convince
yourself that what it's
spitting out is actually
telling you the truth.
And so we're going to look at
the question about, you've
written a program to do
something relatively
complicated, you get
an answer out.
You wouldn't have written the
program if you knew what the
answer was in advance, right?
This is not like a high school
physics experiment where you
know what the answer
should be.
Here you went to the trouble of
writing the program because
you didn't know what
the answer was.
Now the program gives you an
answer, should you believe it,
or shouldn't you believe it?
There are people who say, well,
that's what the computer
said, it must be true.
By now you all have enough
experience with programs that
lie to know that's
not the case.
And so we'll be talking about
how do you go about looking at
the results, and deciding
whether to
believe them or not.
This is a lot of stuff, and
we'll be coming back to this.
I'll be skipping around
from topic this topic.
It may seem a little bit random,
but there's actually a
method to my madness.
Part of it is, I believe that
repeated exposure to some of
these things is a good
way to learn it.
And so I'll be revisiting the
same topic in more and more
depth as we go, rather
than taking a topic
and exhausting it.
So if you think about searches,
this is more of a
breadth first search than
a depth first search.
All right.
Think about these things
as we now go through
the next set of lectures.
So, on for the first example.
Consider the following
situation: a seriously drunken
university student, and I
emphasize university as
opposed to institute here,
is standing in
the middle of a field.
Every second, he takes a step in
some direction or another,
but, you know, just sort of
pretty random, because he's
really out of it.
But the field is constrained
that for the moment we'll
assume that, well, we'll
come back to that.
Now I'm going to ask you
just a question.
So you've got this student who,
every second or so, takes
a step in some direction
or another.
If the student did this for 500
seconds or 1000 seconds,
how far do you expect
the student would be
from where he started?
And I say he because
most of the drunks
are, of course, males.
Anybody want to, what
do you think?
STUDENT: Back where
he started.
PROFESSOR: So we have a thing
that, on average, and of
course since there's randomness
it won't be the
same every time.
Pretty much where he started.
Let me ask a question.
So if you believe that, you
believe he'd be probably the
same distance in 1000 seconds
as in 500 seconds.
Anyone want to posit the
counterposition?
That in fact, the longer the
clock runs, the further the
student will be from
where he started?
Nobody?
All right, what do you think?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right, that's
a good answer.
So the answer there was, well,
if you asked for your best
guess of where the student was,
the best guess is where
the student started.
On the other hand, if you ask
how far was the student from
where he started, the best
guess wouldn't be zero.
That's a great answer, because
it addresses the fact that you
have to be very careful what
question you're asking.
And there are subtle differences
between those two
questions, and they might have
very different answers.
So that's part of that first
step, going from an informal
description, to trying to
formalize it or be more
rigorous about what is
exactly the problem
you're trying to solve.
All right, we'll take a vote.
And everyone has to vote here,
because it's not a democracy
where you're allowed
to not vote.
And the question I'm asking
is, is the expected
difference, does the expected
distance from the origin grow
over time, or remain
constant, roughly?
Who thinks it grows over time?
Who thinks it remains
constant?
Well, the constants have it.
But just because that's the
way most people vote, it
doesn't make it true.
Now let's find out what
the actual truth is.
All right.
So let's start by sketching a
simple model of the situation.
And, one of the things I want
to stress as we do these
things, in developing anything
of this nature, start simple.
So start with some simple
approximation to the real problem.
Check that out, and then, if it
turns out not to be a good
enough model of the world, add
some complications, but don't
start with the complicated
model.
Always start with the
simple model.
So I'm going to start with
the simple model.
And I'm going to assume, as
we've seen before, that we
have Cartesian coordinates and
that the player is, or the
drunk is, standing on a field
that has been cut to resemble
a piece of graph paper.
They got the groundskeeper from
Fenway Park or something,
there, and it looks like a
beautiful piece of paper.
Furthermore, I'm going to assume
for simplicity, that
the student can only go in one
of four directions: north,
south, east, or west. OK, we
could certainly generalize
that, and we will, to something
more complicated,
but for now we'll
keep it simple.
And we'll try and go
to the board and
draw what might happen.
So the student starts here and
takes a step in one direction
or another.
So as the mathematicians say,
without loss of generality,
let's just assume that the
first step is here.
Well what we know for sure, is
after one step the student is
further from the origin
than at the start.
But, that doesn't
tell us a lot.
What happens after
the second step?
Well, the student could come
back to the origin and be
closer, that's one possibility,
the student could
go up here, in which case the
student is a little further,
the student could go down
here, in which case the
student is a little further, or
the student could go over
here, in which case the student
is twice as far.
So we see for the second step,
three times out of four you
get further away.
What happens in the
third step?
So let's look at this one.
Well, the student could come
here, which is closer, could
come here, which is closer,
could go there, which is
further, or could go there,
which is further.
So the third step, with equal
probability, the student is
further or closer if the
student is here.
And we could continue.
So as you can see, it gets
pretty complicated, as you
project how far out it
could always get.
All right, and this is symmetric
to this, but this is
yet a different case.
So, this sort of says, OK, I'm
going to get tired of drawing
things on the board.
So, being who I am, I
say, let's write a
program to do this.
And in fact, what I'm going to
write a program to do, is
simulate what is called
a random walk.
And these will be two themes
we're going to spend
a lot of time on.
Simulation, where we try and
build the model that pretends
it's the real world and
simulates what goes on, and a
random walk.
Now, I'm giving you the classic
story about a random
walk which you can visualize, at
least I hope, but as we'll
see, random walks are very
general, and are used to
address a lot of real problems.
So we'll write this
program, and I want to start
by thinking about designing
the structure of the solution.
Because one of the things I'm
trying to do in this next set
of lectures is bring together
a lot of the things we have
talked about over the course of
the semester, about how we
go about designing and building
programs. Trying to
give you a case study,
if you will.
So let's begin in line with what
Professor Grimson talked
about, about thinking about what
might be the appropriate
data abstractions.
Well, so, I think it would be
good to have a location, since
after all the whole problem
talks about
where the drunk is.
I decided I also wanted to
introduce an abstraction
called compass point to capture
the notion that the
student is going north, south,
east, or west. And later,
maybe I'll decide that needs
to be more complicated and
that the student can go north
by northwest, or maybe all
sorts of things.
But that it would probably pay
to separate the notion of
direction, which is what
this is, from location.
Maybe I should have called
this direction instead of
compass point, but I didn't.
But, I thought about the problem
and said, well, these
things really are separate
locations.
Where you are and where you
might head from there are not
the same, so let's
separate them.
Then I said, well of course,
there is this notion that the
person is in the field, so maybe
I want to have field as
a separate thing.
So think of that as the whole
Cartesian plain, as opposed to
a point in the plane, which
is what the location is.
And finally, I better have a
drunk, because after all this
problem is all about drunks.
All right, so we're now going
to look at some code.
I made this code as simple as
I could to illustrate the
points I wanted to illustrate.
This means I left out a lot
of things that ought to be
included in a good program.
So I want to just warn you.
So for example, I've already
told you that when I build
data abstractions, I always put
in an underbar underbar
str function so that I can print
them when I'm debugging.
Well, you won't see that in this
code, because I felt it
just cluttered the code
up to make the points.
You'll see less defensive
programming than I would
normally use.
But again I wanted to sort of
pare things down to the
essence, since the essence is,
all by itself, probably
confusing enough.
All right.
So let's look at it.
You have this on your
double-sided handout.
This is on side 1one So at the
top, you'll see that I'm
importing three things.
Well, math you've heard about.
And I'm importing that
because I'm going to
need a square root.
Random, you haven't
heard about.
This is a package that lets me
choose things at random, and
I'll show you some of the ways
we can use it, but it actually
provides something that
technically is pseudo-random.
Which means that as far as we
can tell, it's behaving
randomly, but since the computer
is in itself a
deterministic machine, it's
not really random.
But it's so close to random that
we might as well pretend
it is, you can't tell
that it isn't.
So we'll import random.
That will let us make random
guesses of things like, give
me a random number
between 0 and 1.
And it will give you
a random number.
And finally something
called Pylab.
Anyone here use Matlab?
All right, well then, you'll
find Pylab kind of comforting.
Pylab brings into Python a lot
of the features of Matlab And
if you haven't used Matlab,
don't worry, because we'll
explain everything.
For the purposes of this set
of lectures, the next few
lectures, at least, the only
thing we're going to get out
of this is a bunch of tools
for drawing pretty graphs.
And we won't get to those today,
probably, so don't
worry about it.
But it's a nice package, which
you'll be glad to learn.
OK, now let's move on to the
code, which has got things
that should look familiar
to you.
And I know there used
to be a laser -- ah,
here's the laser pointer.
So we'll see at the top
location, it is a class.
By now you've gotten as familiar
as you want to be in
many senses, with classes.
It's got an underbar underbar
init that gives me,
essentially, a point with
an x-coordinate and a
y-coordinate.
It's got get coords, the third
function, or method, and what
you can see what that does
is it's returning a
tuple of two values.
I could have had it get x and
get y, but it turned out, in
fact, my first iteration of this
it did have a get x and
get y, and when I looked at the
code that was using it, I
realized whenever I got one,
I wanted both, and it just
seemed kind of silly, so I did
something that made the using
code a little bit better.
It's got get distance,
the last method.
You saw this in Professor
Grimson's lecture, where he
used the Pythagorean theorem
to basically compute the
distance on a hypotenuse, to
tell you how far a point was
from the origin.
That's why I wanted math.
And then the one thing it has
that it's unlike the example
you saw from Professor
Grimson, was
up here, this move.
And this basically takes a
point, a location, and an x-
and a y- coordinate, and returns
another location, in
which I've incremented the
x and the y, perhaps
incrementing by 0.
And so now you can see how I'm
going to be able to mimic 1
step or any number of steps
by using this move.
Any questions about this?
Great, all right.
The next one you'll see
is compass point.
Remember, this was the
abstraction that was going to
let me conveniently deal
with directions.
The first thing you'll see is,
there's a global variable in
the sense that it's external
to any of the methods, and
you'll note it's not self dot
possibles, but just possibles.
Because I don't want
a new copy of
this for every instance.
And this tells me the possible
directions, which I've
abbreviated as n, s, e, and w.
And I leave it to you to
figure out what those
abbreviations stand for.
Then I've got init, which takes
a point and it first
checks to see if the point
is in self dot possibles.
Should I have bothered
saying self?
Do I need to write self there?
This is a test of classes.
It'll work.
What do you think?
Who thinks I need to write self,
and who thinks I don't?
Who thinks I need to write
self, raise your hand?
Who thinks I don't need
to write self?
The don't needs have it.
So in an act of intense bravery,
since I have not run
it without this, we'll see what
happens when it comes
time to run the program.
So if point is in possibles, it
will take self dot p t will
be assigned p t.
Otherwise, I'll raise
a value error.
And this is a little piece of
programming, and what I
typically do at a minimum, when
I raise these exceptions,
is make sure that it says
where it's coming from.
So this says it's gonna raise
this value error in the method
compass point dot underbar
underbar
init, underbar underbar.
This is so when I run the
program, and I see a message,
I don't have to scratch my head
figuring out where did
things go wrong?
So just a convention
I follow a lot.
And then I've got move here.
And I'll move self some
distance, and you can
see what I'm doing.
If self is north, I'm going
to return 0 in distance.
So I'm now getting a tuple,
which will basically be used
to say, all right, we're going
to implement x by 0 and y by
distance, which is
what you think of
about moving due north.
And if it's south, we'll
increment x by 0, and
increment y by minus distance,
heading down the graph.
And similarly for east and west.
And in the sad event I
call this with something that's
not north, south, east,
or west, again I'll raise
an exception.
OK, little bit at a time.
So I hope that nothing here
looks complicated.
In fact, it should all
look kind of boring.
Now we'll get to field,
which should look
a little less boring.
So now I've got a field.
And, well, before I get to
field, I want to go back to
something about the first 2
abstractions: compass point
and location.
Whenever we design one of these
abstractions, we're
making some things possible and
some things impossible.
We're making decisions, and
so what decisions are
encapsulated in these
first two classes?
Well, one decision is that it's
a 2-dimensional space.
I basically said we've
got x and y and
that's all we've got.
This student cannot fly.
The student cannot dig a hole
and go into the ground, we're
only moving in 2 dimensions,
so that's fixed.
The other decision I made is
that this student can only
move in 1 of 4 directions.
So, couple of good
things here.
One, I've simplified the world,
which will make it
easier for us to see
what's going on.
But two, I know where I've
made those decisions, and
later if I want to go back and
say, you know it'd be fun if
the student could fly, let's
say we're a drunken pigeon
instead of a drunken student.
Or it would be a good idea to
realize that, in fact, they
might head off at
any weird angle.
I know what code I
have to change.
It's encapsulated in
a single place.
So that's why possibles is part
of compass point, rather
than scattered throughout
the program.
So this is nice way
to think about it.
All right, let's move on
and look at field.
So field, it's got an init, it
takes a self, a drunk, and a
location, and puts the drunk in
the field at that location.
It can move.
So let's look at what happens
when we try and move self in
some direction, in
some distance.
We say the old location is the
current location, and then x c
and y c, think of that as
x-change and y-change, get c p
dot move of dist. Where is it
gonna find c p dot move?
It's going to use compass point
dot move, because as
we'll see, c p is an object of
type, of class, compass point.
So this is a normal and typical
way we structure
things with classes.
The move of one class is defined
using the move of
another class.
This gives us the modularity
we so prize.
And then I'll say self dot
location is old loc dot move
of x c and x c.
Now this is oldloc dot move is
going to get the move from
class location.
And you'll remember, that was
the thing that just added
appropriate values to x and y.
So I'll use compass point to
get those values, and then
oldloc to get the
new location.
Then I'll be able to get
the loc and I'll be
able to get the drunk.
So, let me ask the same question
about field I've
asked about the others?
What interesting decisions, if
any, have I embodied in the
way I've designed and
implemented this abstraction?
There's at least one pretty
interesting decision here.
Just interesting to me because
my first version was far more
complicated.
Well, how many drunks can I
have in a field at a time?
We have an answer which will
not be recorded, because it
was merely raising a finger,
but it happened to be the
correct number of
fingers: one.
And it was this finger that
got pointed at me.
We've embodied the fact that
you can have one drunk,
exactly one drunk
in the field.
This is a solitary alcoholic.
Later we might say, well, it
would be fun to put a whole
bunch of drunken students in
and watch what happens when
they bump into each other.
And we'll actually later give
you a problem set, not with
students, but with other things
where there might be
more than one in a field.
But here, I've made
that decision.
But again, I know where I've
made it, and if later I go
back and say let's put a bunch
of them in, I don't have to
change compass point, I don't
have to change location, I
only have to change field.
And we'll also see, I don't
have to change drunk.
So again, it's very nice that
the class structure, the
modularity let's us have
decisions in exactly one place
in our code.
Usually important.
All right, now let's
look at drunk.
So the drunk has a name.
And, like everything else,
a move operation.
This is the most complicated
and interesting move.
Because here is where I'm
encapsulating the decisions
about what the drunk
actually does.
That the drunk, for example,
doesn't head north and just
keep on going.
So, let's look at what
happens here.
It's got three parameters: self,
the field the drunk is
moving in, and time.
How long the drunk
is going to move.
And you may notice something
that you haven't seen before,
at least some of you,
time equals one
is sitting up there.
There.
Python allows us to have what
are called default values for
parameters.
What this says is that if I call
this method without that
last argument, rather than
getting an error message
saying it expects three
arguments it only got two, it
chooses the default value,
in this case one
for the third argument.
This is actually a pretty useful
programming paradigm,
because there's often a
very sensible default.
And it can simplify things.
It's not an intrinsically
interesting or important part
of what I'm showing you here.
The reason I'm showing it is,
you'll be getting a problem
set in which default values are
there because we're using
some other things.
And as you bring in libraries
and modules from elsewhere,
you'll find that there are
a lot of these things.
And in fact a lot of the
functions you've already been
using for the built-in types
happen to have default values.
For example, when you look at
things in the init part of a
range, it's actually choosing,
say, 0 as a start.
But don't worry about it.
This just says if you don't
pass it a time, use 1.
And then what it does, is it
says, if field dot get drunk
is not equal to self,
raise an exception.
OK, you've asked me to move a
drunk, it doesn't happen to be
in the field.
That's not very interesting.
But now we come to the
interesting part.
For i in range time, here by
the way range does have a
default value of 0,
and since I didn't
supply it, it used it.
Point equals compass point,
and here's the most
interesting thing, random
dot choice of
compass point dot possibles.
Random dot choice is a function
in the random module
which we've imported and it
takes as an argument a
sequence, a list of some sort,
a container, and it picks a
random element out of that.
So here we're passing it in,
four possible values, and it's
just going to pick one
of them at random.
So you can see by my having
encapsulated the possibles
array in compass point, I don't
have to worry in drunk
about how many possible
directions this person could
head off in.
And then it calls field dot
move, with the resultant
point, and in this case one.
All right?
We've now finished all of this
sort of groundwork that we
need to go and actually build
the simulation that will model
our problem.
So let's look at how
we use all of this.
I've now got a function perform
trial, which will take
a time in a field.
So I'll get a starting point of
f dot getloc, wherever the
drunk happens to be at this
point in time in the field.
And then for t in range 1 to
time plus 1, I'm going to call
field dot get drunk, that will
give me the drunk that's in
the field, and then
I'll get the move
function for that drunk.
So what you see here is I can
actually, in this dot
notation, take advantage of the
fact, where are we, we're
down here, I've got to get
far enough away that
I can see it --
Where was I?
STUDENT: You were in
the right place
right there, down slightly.
PROFESSOR: -- down slightly,
here, right.
I've called the function, which
has returned an object,
f dot get drunk returns an
object of class drunk.
And then I can select the method
associated with that
object, the move method,
and move the drunk.
This gets back to a point that
we've emphasized before, that
these objects are first class
citizens in Python.
You can use functions and
methods to generate them, and
use them just as if
you'd typed them.
So that will get me that, and
then I'll call the move of
that drunk with the field.
Then I'll get the location,
the new location, and then
I'll say, distance equals new
loc dot get distance of start,
how far is the new location
from wherever the starting
location was?
I'll append it to a list,
and then I'll return it.
So now I have a list, and in the
list I have how far away
the drunk is after
each time step.
I'm just collecting the
list of distances.
So I don't have a list of
locations, I don't know where,
I can't plot the trajectory, but
I can plot the distances.
OK, now, let's put
it all together.
So I'll say the drunk is equal
to, is drunk of Homer Simpson.
I had thought about using the
name of someone on campus and
decided that, since it was
going to be taped for
OpenCourseWare, I didn't
want to go there.
Sometimes I lack courage.
Then for i in range 3, and all
this says is I'm going to
test, I'm going to run the
simulation three different
times, f is equal to field of
drunk and location 0, 0,
starting in the middle
of the field.
Distances equal perform trial
500, 500 steps on that field,
and the rest of it is magic you
don't need to understand
because we'll come back to next
lecture, which is, how do
I put all this in a
pretty picture?
So ignore all of that for now,
and that's just the Pylab
stuff for plotting
the pictures.
All right, we're there,
let's run it.
Huh.
Remember the change we made?
Guess what?
Well, we know how to fix that.
And we'll come back to
it and ask what's
really going on here.
What does self refer to here?
It refers to the class compass
point, rather than an instance
of the class.
Again, driving home the point
that classes are objects just
like everything else.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, sorry.
Thank you.
It did it have in here, right.
All right, now let's run
it, see what we get.
We get a picture.
Well, so we see that, at least
for these three tests, the
majority of the public
was wrong.
It seems that the longer we run
it, the further from the
origin Homer seems
to be getting.
Well, let's try it again.
Maybe we just got unlucky
three times.
You can see from the divergence
here, that, of
course, a lot of things go on.
I hope you can also see the
advantage of being able to
plot it rather than having
to look at those arrays.
Well, we get different answers,
but you know what?
The trend still seems
pretty clear.
It does seem over time, that
we wander further away.
I know, further away.
So, looks at least for
the moment, that
perhaps we were wrong.
Well, this is rather silly for
me to keep running it over and
over again.
So clearly what I ought
to do is, do it in a
more organized way.
So now if we go back, and see
the, kind of the right way to
do it, I'm going to get rid of
this stuff here, which was
used just to stop the previous
computation.
I'm going to write a function
called perform sim.
And what that does, is it takes
the time and the number
of trials that we
wanted to do.
It takes distlist equals the
empty list in this case, to
start with, and then it is
basically going to call
perform trial, the function we
already looked at over and
over again.
And get a whole bunch of
lists back, a list each
time it calls it.
And then, compute an average.
Well, not yet, so it says, it
says d equals drunk, field
start in zero, distances equals
perform trial, append
the new list, and what
it does, is it
returns a list of lists.
Where each list is what we had
for the previous trials.
Make sense?
And then I'm going to
have 1 more function
call, answer a question.
Which takes the maximum time and
the number of trials, and
it's going to do
some statistics
on all of the lists.
We'll come back to this
a week from today.
If you are, have absolutely
nothing to do for the next
week, I'll give you a hint.
I have salted a bug here in
this latest code, and you
might have some fun looking
at what that bug is.